Part 3 of Chilling Adventures of Sabrina is
stuffed with easter eggs, hidden references
and monstrous secrets buried in each episode.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
I'm Jan and in this video I'm revealing 28
devilish details you might have missed in
Chilling Adventures Season 3, including the
Riverdale easter eggs that reveal a very weirdly
connected universe.
There will, of course, be spoilers so take
care if you haven't caught up.
Part 3 opens with Sabrina's terrifying nightmare
of wandering into Hell and discovering Nick
encased in stone.
It's a clever bit of foreshadowing for Sabrina's
own fate later in the season when she gets
trapped in the Ninth Circle of Hell by Caliban.
It's not until the seventh episode that Robin
reveals he's a hobgoblin to Theo.
But there was a clue to his true identity
all the way back in the fourth episode when
Carcosa called Robin by his full name:
"Thank you for warning us Robin Goodfellow."
The name "Robin Goodfellow" is often used
in English folklore for a mischievous sprite
or hobgoblin, and in English mythology and
literature such as Shakespeare's A Midsummer
Night's Dream, Robin Goodfellow also goes
by the name of "Puck".
Chilling Adventures begins to introduce new
Lovecraftian monsters into its universe when
Blackwood calls upon an amphibian-like beast
to rise out of the waters of Loch Ness.
Blackwood calls the creature the "Deep One",
the same name as a species of water-dwelling
monsters from H.P.
Lovecraft's novella The Shadow Over Innsmouth.
And another of Lovecraft's sci-fi horrors
is referenced when Zelda weighs up the covens'
options to avoid getting killed by the pagans.
"We could flee perhaps to the Mountains of
Madness."
"At the Mountains of Madness" is a novella
by Lovecraft that features a dangerous alien
civilisation in Antarctica that lies beyond
a mountain range even higher than the Himalayas.
And the word Carcosa, the name of the malevolent
carnival leader who arrives in Greendale,
first appeared in several 19th-century short
stories as an ancient mysterious city before
being used as the name of an alien city within
the Lovecraftian Cthulhu Mythos.
In that universe, Carcosa is home to Hastur,
a monstrous deity who's also known as "The
Unspeakable One", something which ties in
to how Blackwood describes the Eldritch Terrors
he plans to bring into the world.
"Return to me the egg, and we'll bear witness
to the birth of the unspeakable."
Carcosa and the pagans plan to resurrect their
Old Gods in an event they call The Great Flowering.
For the ceremony, they place a sacrificial
virgin inside a giant green plant statue,
much like the virgin sacrifice that a group
of pagans carry out inside a giant wicker
man statue in the 1973 horror movie The Wicker
Man.
And the pagans in Greendale also wear animal
masks at the coven's Hare Moon celebration,
just like the pagans do in The Wicker Man.
At the carnival, the Ferris wheel that Theo
and Robin ride is called "The Berlanti Wheel",
an easter egg to prolific TV producer Greg
Berlanti, whose shows include Chilling Adventures,
Riverdale, Arrow, Supergirl, and You.
This season also includes several references
to the modern horror movie "Midsommar" about
a pagan cult.
In Chilling Adventures, when Sabrina returns
to find the pagans have created an apocalypse
on Earth, she's startled by a couple of plant-like
human zombies, who appear to have a pair of
yellow flowers growing in their eyes.
This is a creepy nod to one of the pagan human
sacrifices in the movie.
In fact, Sabrina showrunner Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa
has specifically said that films like that
and The Wicker Man were 'always the kind of
horror that [he] wanted to get to play with
and infuse into Part 3.'
And the flower crowns the Greendale coven
wear for The Hare Moon festival, which are
an ancient tradition used in many pagan ceremonies,
also recently appeared in Midsommar.
After arriving in Hell, Sabrina asks Caliban
how they can get to Pandemonium, and he answers:
"Follow the blood-red road where it flows,
and there you'll find the throne of Hell."
That advice is a bloody reference to The Wizard
of Oz and the Good Witch of the North's instructions
to Dorothy on how to reach the Emerald City.
"All you do is follow the yellow brick road."
And like Dorothy in the Wizard of Oz, Sabrina
and the gang also come across their own Tin
Man in the form of Tommy, Harvey's brother
who died in the first season of Chilling Adventures.
Like the classic movie's Tin Man, Tommy also
has problems with his heart.
But while the original Tin Man believed he
lacked a heart, Tommy's heart is on the outside
of his tin costume.
Another classic tale is referenced in Hell's
Forest of Torment.
When Sabrina and Roz go to pick the Fleur
du Mal that Dorian Gray has asked them to
collect, Sabrina warns her friend that if
they prick themselves on the flower's thorns,
they'll go to sleep and never wake up.
That was also the fate of the princess in
Sleeping Beauty when she pricked her finger
on a cursed spinning wheel.
"It's like something out of a fairy tale."
And remember that princess Aurora was also
known by the prickly, flowery name of Briar
Rose.
Also in Chilling Adventures, the flower even
sings and calls to Sabrina and Roz luring
them into a potential trap, similar to how
Maleficent entranced and tricked Aurora into
pricking herself.
And later, after they bring Nick back from
Hell to the mortal world, Sabrina wakes him
with a kiss, akin to how Sleeping Beauty was
woken from her curse.
The evil flower that Dorian Gray asks Sabrina
to get for him is also a reference to a set
of poems by Charles Baudelaire called "Les
Fleurs du Mal".
Appropriately for Chilling Adventures, Baudelaire's
collection of poems includes one called "The
Litanies of Satan" which fiercely criticised
the 19th-century Church and also inverted
several prayers from the Catholic Mass and
substituted Mary's name with Satan's.
Likewise, Chilling Adventures also likes to
flip common religious expressions:
"In other words..
Back the heaven off."
And in Part 3, Zelda's prayer "Hail Lilith"
is an inversion of the traditional Catholic
prayer "Hail Mary".
"Hail Lilith, full of disgrace.
Cursed are you amongst women, and cursed is
the fruit of thy womb, demons."
Sabrina manages to reverse the pagan apocalypse,
but in the process she also decides to allow
a double of herself to exist at the same time.
This twin Sabrina situation is something that
already occurred in the 90s sitcom Sabrina
The Teenage Witch.
At the end of the third season of the old-school
show, Sabrina met her identical twin Katrina
and they had to undergo a test to find out
which sibling was the evil one.
When the test revealed that Sabrina's sister
Katrina was the evil sibling, Katrina was
sent to live in the Twin Cities in a place
known as the "Other Realm".
While one Sabrina returns to Greendale in
Chilling Adventures, the other goes to Hell
where Lilith prepares her for her full-time
role as Queen of Hell.
Sabrina's style, including her coronation
dress and white makeup, evoke the look of
English Tudor monarch Elizabeth I, who was
known as "the Virgin Queen" and whose reign
included the attempted invasion of England
by the Spanish Armada.
On top of that, Sabrina's coronation seems
to pay specific homage to the final scene
of the late-90s movie Elizabeth, with each
queen's people bowing down to her and touching
her dress, and the queen signalling her ascent
to the throne with a little hand gesture.
The parallels between Queen Elizabeth I and
Queen Sabrina of Hell become even more striking
when Lilith speaks to Sabrina about what's
in store for the new young queen.
"Every queen must be made battle-ready.
Every girl must prepare for war.
Let nothing touch you.
Let no man hold power over you."
And emphasising that at least Hell-bound Sabrina
will be uninterested in love, Sabrina tells
Lucifer.
"I am ready, Father, to be married to Hell."
Much as Elizabeth I was considered as being
wed to her kingdom.
In Part 3, Ambrose plays a key part in events
when he and Prudence track down Father Blackwood
who's gone into hiding in Loch Ness, Scotland.
When they arrive, Ambrose explains that he
already has some knowledge of the location:
"Loch Ness lies atop a powerful rift along
the Earth's ley lines.
Aleister Crowley himself once harnessed its
energies for his own higher magicks."
Ambrose's familiarity with Crowley's life
stems from a time when Crowley acted as a
kind of mentor to Ambrose.
"My boy, how did you ever end up as part of
a plot to blow up the Vatican?"
"A young Crowley.
He was brilliant, charismatic, and devoted
to the Dark Lord."
In real life, Aleister Crowley was an English
occultist who gained notoriety for many things,
including establishing the religion of Thelema,
aspects of which have inspired Wicca and Satanism.
And like in the show, Crowley did actually
live in Loch Ness for a period of his life.
The show's nine circles of hell are inspired
by Dante's Inferno, a drawing of which appears
in the background on a school blackboard in
the first episode, another clue that by the
end of Part 3, Sabrina will travel all the
way to the Ninth Circle of Hell.
In Dante's epic poem, the Ninth Circle is
reserved for people who've committed treachery,
including Judas Iscariot.
So, it's fitting that that's where Caliban
tricks Sabrina and betrays her trust.
On top of that, the Ninth Circle is also where
Sabrina breaks the promise she made to future
Sabrina to complete the time loop by taking
her place in the stone prison.
By the way, the fact that Chilling Adventures
encases its traitors in stone is another hat
tip to Dante's Inferno where most of those
condemned to Hell's Ninth Circle are trapped
in ice.
Also in Ms Wardwell's classroom is another
blackboard where you can spot a mention of
"Paradise Lost", an epic poem by John Milton.
It was in "Paradise Lost" that Milton coined
the term "Pandemonium" for the capital of
Hell.
Not only is Pandemonium a crucial location
in Part 3, but Caliban himself is also sculpted
from the city's clay.
The backstory for Herod's Crown also notably
connects to the history of one of Riverdale's
most significant families, the Blossoms.
In Part 3, Ambrose discovers this first item
of the Unholy Regalia was passed between numerous
people, the last known one being:
"Private Benjamin Blossom who recovered the
crown from Hitler's bunker in 1945."
Interestingly, Ambrose goes on to explain
that when Benjamin Blossom brought Herod's
Crown back to Riverdale, he was murdered by
a group of occultists who wanted possession
of the magical unholy relic.
When Sabrina and Ambrose visit Riverdale to
locate the crown, they discover it's hidden
in a maple syrup tree, which is especially
fitting because maple syrup has been part
of the Blossom family business.
In fact, the connection between the Blossoms
and King Herod seems particularly appropriate
as history and myth remembers Herod for having
executed numerous male children including
several of his own sons.
And, of course, season 1 spoilers for Riverdale,
that show kicks off with the murder of Jason
Blossom, who it's later revealed was killed
by his own father who was using the family
syrup business as a front for selling drugs.
It's interesting that actor Jonathan Whitesell
who plays Robin the Hobgoblin in Sabrina also
played the part of Kurtz on Riverdale.
Kurtz was a member of the Gargoyle Gang.
But how can the same actor play two different
characters in two shows that are supposedly
connected?
Well, perhaps it could be another example
of the recurring theme of twins in both shows?
In Chilling Adventures, there's the Blackwood
twins, Principal Hawthorne's twin who was
absorbed in the womb, the image of Hilda and
Zelda as conjoined twins, and now, after much
hinting in previous seasons, Sabrina has a
double too!
Or perhaps it's all part of the shape-shifting
ability of Puck or Robin Goodfellow characters
in English folklore?
When Sabrina approaches Jimmy Platt's ice
cream truck, you can see it reads "A Chilling
Adventure".
That isn't just a play on the title of the
show though; it's also a hint at the chilly
fate that awaits Sabrina later in the episode
when she ends up trapped in the evil ice cream
seller's freezer.
Curiously the same actor who plays Jimmy Platt,
is also going to appear on an episode of Riverdale
as a quiz show host.
This again raises the question of how the
same actor can play different characters in
a shared universe.
Previously, in an interview with Entertainment
Tonight, Chilling Adventures and Riverdale
showrunner Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa explained
how Ben, a character who's already dead in
Riverdale, later showed up as a pizza delivery
guy in Greendale.
According to Aguirre-Sacasa, Ben's cameo "suggests
a very deep mythology where time and space
bend."
And even though Ben was dead in Riverdale,
"in Greendale, everyone pops up - the dead
don't stay dead long [there]".
There's an amusing reference to the crazy
events that go on in Greendale's neighbouring
town when we see the "Welcome to Riverdale"
sign.
On the back you can spot some Jughead graffiti
which dubs the town "Murder capital of the
world".
And in the Riverdale spin-off show Katy Keene,
Josie also refers to her hometown in the same
way.
"I am from Riverdale.
It is the murder capital of the world."
After Hilda turns into Spider-Hilda, she asks
Dr Cee to get her a hamburger and a milkshake
from a diner in Riverdale, undoubtedly referencing
everyone's favourite meeting place in Riverdale,
Pop's Chock'Lit Shoppe.
Spider-Hilda also ends up eating a Riverdale
Southside Serpent gang member who wanders
into Dr Cee's bookstore looking for something
to eat.
Another Riverdale actor who makes an appearance
on Chilling Adventures is Nathalie Boltt,
aka Penelope Blossom, spoilers for Riverdale,
the nefarious mastermind behind the Black
Hood and the Gargoyle King.
In Chilling Adventures, she pops up in New
Orleans.
However, it turns out it's not the real Penelope
Blossom, but rather Prudence who's using Penelope's
form for a glamour trick while she and Ambrose
are on the hunt for Blackwood.
The title of the final episode, "Sabrina Is
Legend", is an intriguing reference to the
2007 movie "I Am Legend", based on the book
of the same name.
The movie is known for its alternate ending
in which, spoilers for the film, Will Smith
gets a happier ending than the original one
shown in cinemas.
Likewise in Chilling Adventures, Sabrina creates
an alternate and happier timeline for herself
when she decides not to complete the time
loop as future Sabrina advised.
And if you want to know much more about the
consequences Sabrina will face in Part 4 as
a result of altering the timeline, watch my
Ending Explained video.
You can tap the link here or click the link
in the video description.
So, did you spot any other cool details or
references in Part 3?
And what were your favourite moments this
season?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then a like and a share
are hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my next Sabrina video or tap
right for another video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!